لا يستجيبون لهم بشيء الا كباسط كفيه الى
الماء ليبلغ فاه وما هو
ببالغه وما دعاء الكافرين الا في
ضلال ولله يسجد من في السماوات والارض
طوعا وكرها وظلالهم بالغدو
والاصال قوله تعالى له دعوه الحق له يعني
لله
لله الذي يرسل
الصواعق لله الذي يعلم ما تحمل كل
انثى
لله
الذي
يستوي علمه سبحانه وتعالى فينا و نستوي في
علمه منا
من هو مستخف بالليل وسارب
بالنهار
له دعوه
الحق ودعوه
الحق قيل دعوه
هنا يعني الشعار
والكلمه كلمه
الحق ما يدعو اليه اهله سبحانه
وتعالى وذلك لا اله الا
الله
وقيل دعوه الحق يعني عباده الحق له عباده
الحق سبحانه
وتعالى لان
الدعاء في اللغه وفي القران يطلق ويراد به
السؤال ويطلق ويراد به
العباده الله سبحانه
وتعالى
يقول هنا له دعوه الحق يعني عباده
الحق
العباده الحقه له سبحانه
وتعالى
ومعناه التوحيد له
ذلك وقيل دعوه الحق يعني مساله الحق
السؤال
الحق
واما ما سواه من
الالهه فلها دعوه الباطل كيف
ذاك يعني اذا كانوا في راحه وفي دعا وفي
سع فانهم يدعون هذه الالهه لاسباب
مختلفه واما اذا كانوا في
البحر
وتلاطم
الامواج وظنوا
انهم
مغرق وظنوا انهم مغرقون دعوا الله
مخلصين له
الدين لان انجيتنا من
هذه فهذه هي دعوه
الحق فالله سبحانه وتعالى له ذلك
خاصه
يعني عند الشد
يدعون الله سبحانه وتعالى
وحده فدعوه الحق
له لان عند هذه الشدائد كل هذه الاسباب
الاخرى التي من اجلها تدعى هذه
الالهه كل هذه الاسباب
تتساقط ما يكون لها
قيمه يعني منهم من يعبد هذه
الالهه من
باب الاعتزاز بالاباء
والاجداد ومنهم من باب العادات
والتقاليد
ومنهم من
باب
التشفع يعني يطلبون
الشفاعه من هذه الالهه عند
الله لكن اذا كان
الامر امر جدي
فانهم يعون الله وحده دون ما
سواه لغير
سبب
لانهم يتعبدون الله ويريدون
النجاه تقت
ارواحهم بهه
الدعوه فه دعوه
الحق وهذا له خاصه سبحانه
وتعالى زي ما بيقولوا
بعظمه
لسانهم
يعني لسان
حالهم ناطق بالحجه عليهم هم يعبدون غير
الله لكن شلون عند الشدائد لا تعبدون الا
الله فهذه حجه
عليهم لذلك يقول له دعوه
الحق والذين يدعون من دونه لا يستجيبون
لهم
بشيء الا كباسط
كفيه يقول والذين يدعون من
دونه يعني
الالهه وهذه الالهه هي في الحقيقه لا تعقل
ليس
كذلك والذي لا يعقل في اللغه
العربيه
فانه يطلق عليه
بالتاني وبغير
الواو يكون
جمع تانيث
تقول الثعلب جاء والثعالب
جاءت رايت
الثعالب
وكذلك جاء
الاسد
بالتذكير جاءت الاسد يعني جمع اسود
جاءت
ف
تؤنث جمع ما لا
يعقل واما هنا قال
والذين
يدعون من دونه لا يستجيبون
يستجيبون
هذا
جمع ما
يعقل والسبب ان هذه الالهه هي حقيقه
جماد
لكنها خلط بين الاصنام والالهه
والاموات
يعني رجال
كانوا بني ادمين في الارض يعتقدون فيهم
اعتقادات انهم يعني من المقربين الى الله
او انهم وانهم ثم يموتون فيعكف على قبورهم
كذلك
الملائكه فلذلك
غلب ما يعقل على ما لا
يعقل فكان ال
متوقع وما يدعون من دونه لا تستجيب لهم
لكن
غلب ما يعقل على ما لم يعقل
مثل الحمد لله رب
العالمين ايش العالمين
العالمين الجامع بالرفع يكون
العالمون العالمون ما ما هو العالمون جميع
الخلق هذا
عالمون لانه جمع
عالم
والعالم تقول مثلا عالم الانس عالم الجن
عالم النبات
عالم الذباب
عالم
وهكذا فهو رب العالمين يعني العوالم لكن
جاء بدلا من عوالم جاء العالمين لانه
غلب في الذكر ما يعقل يعني الانس والجن
والملائكه هذه الاصناف تعقل فغلبت
لشرفها لانه اكبر دليل على وجود الصانع
وجود الخالق سبحانه
وتعالى فعلى كل حال لا يستجيبون لهم غلب
العاقل غلب ما يعق على ما لا يعقل في بعض
الايات
ياتي
بالعكس ياتي ب ولله مثلا هنا جاء ولله
يسجد
من
من هذا لما يعقل وفي بعض الايات ولله يسجد
ما ما
تغليبا لما يعقل تاره وتاره اخرى للكثره
لان الاكثر ما ما لا
يعقل ليش مره تيجي الايه هيك ومره تيجي
الايه هيك السبب باختلاف السياق حسب
السياق احيانا يناسب السياق هذا واحيانا
يناسب السياق هذا يعني مثلا في القران
واطيعوا
الله ورسوله واطيعوا الله
والرسول واطيعوا الله واطيعوا
الرسول هذه شو معناها حكما نفس
الحكم نفس
الحكم لكن تاتي هذه تاره هكذا و تاره هكذا
واطيعوا الله ورسوله واطيعوا الله واطيعوا
الرسول شو الفرق بين الرسول ورسوله شو
الفرق بين اعاده
الفعل اطيع الله اطيع الرسول اطيع الله
والرسول الجواب الفرق من ناحيه بلاغيه بس
واما من ناحيه المعنى المعنى نفس
المعنى طيب لماذا ياتي او يقع الاختيار في
هذه الايه هكذا وفي هذه الايه هكذا الجواب
السياق
السياق السياق في
القران هو الذي
لابد من تحكيمه في مثل هذه الاشياء تنظر
الى
السياق السياق وجو
الصوره هو الذي يجعل الاختيار يقع على هذا
او على هذا او على
ذاك هو يقول والذين
يدعون من
دونه يعني هذه الالهه حتى لو كانت من
الملائكه حتى لو كانت من
ا
الانبياء لا يستجيبون لهم
بشيء يعني ما يعقل
منها لا
يستجيب فضلا عم من لا يعقل
منها لا يستجيبون لهم بشيء هذه نكره في
سياق النفي تعوم يعني باي شيء ولا حتى
بقشره بصله هذا كل وهم في وهم
كله
وهذا ل انتزاع هذه الشبهه من قلوب
العرب كانوا يعتقدون شيء من الاستجابه
الجواب لا لا يستجيبون لهم
بشيء
الا كباسط كفيه الا
هنا هذا
يسمى استثناء
منقطع ايش الاستثناء المنقطع قصته طويله
لكن المهم من هذه القصه لنا ان الاستثناء
المنقطع كيف تعرف انه استثناء
منقطع تاخذ
كلمه
الا تحط
مكانها
لكن اذا استقام المعنى هذا اسمه استثناء
منقطع يعني
مثلا يقول
تعالى لست عليهم بمسيطر
الا من تولى وكفر هل هو مسيطر على من تولى
وكفر الجواب
لا فايش معناه لكن لكن من تولى وكفر
فيعذبه الله العذاب
الاكبر
ماشي هذا اسمه استثناء
منقطع لا يذوقون فيها
بردا ولا
شرابا الا حميما وغساقا هل الحميم والساق
من البرد
والشراب
لا اذا ناخذ مكان هذا الاستثناء ونحط
مكانه ايش
لكن فنشوف كيف يستقيم الكلام لا يذوقون
فيها بردا ولا شرابا لكن حميما
وغساقا يستقيم الكلام صحيح
هذا اسمه استثناء منقطع يسميه النحاه
الاستثناء
المنقطع فعلى كل حال هنا استثناء منقطع
لان الله
تعالى نفى كل الاستجابه
تماما ما في استجابه لاي
شيء والله عز وجل اضاف الباء
الزائده يعني قال لا يستجيبون لهم
بشيء يعني هذه زياده على لا يستجيبون
لهم لا يستجيبون لهم
شيئا لا يستجيبون لهم
بشيء فالنفي هنا لكل
شيء حتى لا يبقى في القلوب شيء من
الشبهه مهما
تتوهمون ايها الناس من استجابه هذه
الالهه
لكم هذه الاصنام هؤلاء الصالحون
بزعمكم هذه الملائكه هؤلاء الانبياء مهما
تزعم مهما
تتوهمون فانها لا تستجيب
لكم لا تستجيب لكم لا تستجيب لكم شيئا لا
تستجيب لكم
بشيء فيجي بعدها
الا فممكن يفهم هنا الا ايش
يعني الا يعني لا يستجيبون لكم لهم بشيء
الا يعني يستجيبون بهذه بس هذا غير
مراد لان
الله اخبر انها لا
تستجيب ولا تستطيع حتى لو ارادت ان تستجيب
ما
تستطيع فهنا ناتي ونحط كلمه ايش لكن لانه
استثناء
منقطع كباسط كفيه خلينا نقرا الايه هيك له
دعوه
الحق والذين يدعون من دونه لا يستجيبون
لهم بشيء لا كباسط
كفيه يعني حالهم حال باسط الكفي باسط كفيه
الى الماء ليبلغ ثاه وما هو ببالغ ايش
معنى هذا
المثل على كل
حال معنى هذا الكلام في الراجح الذي عليه
اكثر علماء
التفسير هو الذي يمد يديه الى
الماء من طرف
البئر ويدعو هذا الماء مهما كان
عطشا فان هذا الماء لا يبلغ فاه اذا ما
كان
معه يحتاج دلو صح ولا لا يعني يفتح البئر
ويمد ايديه على
هالمي تعالي يا ميه
تعالي ب تجيه الميه مهما مد ايديه مهما
ركز مهما اخلص في مد
اليدين فان هذا الماء لا يستجيب له ولا
يبلغ
فاهه مستحيل يحصل وهم
هكذا فهذا الذي يفعل هكذا يمد يديه يبسط
يديه الى الماء ليبلغ ف
هو في ذهنه انه ك
كرب لكن هذا كله ايش
وهم هذا كله
وهم هذا
قول قول اخر ولعله
الارجح ان العرب في
لغتهم يطلقون هذا على الذي لا يتمكن من
الشيء
و ولو كان قريبا ولو كان هو يحس فعلا انه
متمكن من الشيء لكن في الحقيقه ليس متمكن
مني يق له باسط كفيه الى الماء يعني
مثلا
الذي يضع يديه في
الماء ويحاول يخرج الماء باديه هيك
الماء يبقى في يديه ام يسيل يسيل
يذهب لان الفروج بين الاصابع وكذا فهو
مهما كان قويا مهما
كان شده بطشه باليد فانه لا
يستطيع ان يتاتى بنتيجه من
الماء فكذلك
هنا
هذه
الالهه
استجابتهم
اوهام فان هذه الالهه لا تستجيب لهم
بشيء الا يعني لكن كباسط كفيه يعني الحال
حال الوهم بس هذا كله
وهم كباسط كفيه الى الماء ليبلغ فاه وما
هو
بالغه وما دعاء الكافرين الا في ضلال يعني
في ضياع وفي
ذهاب بدون
فائده يذهب
سدن هذا اسمه
ضلال يقول تعالى ولله يسجد من في السماوات
والارض طوعا وكره وظلالهم بالغدو
والاصال وان شاء الله نبحث معاني هذه
الايه غدا والله اعلم صلى الله وسلم على
نبينا
محمد سه
الر
قران ver 12
13 14
15 الله سبحانه
وتعالى
‏the who you
the to inspire fear and hope in
you and he likewise develops these very
heavy clouds
overhead heavy with
rain سبحانه وتالى
الله
‏thunder the thunder its
itself proclaims the
glory and
pra الله سبحانه
وتعالى and the angs
منفه and the angels they proclaim his
glory with fear of him in spite of their
‏str and
sends the
light and afflicts with them ands them
on whomever he
chooses all the while they
argue about
allah argue about
the عليه
وس
الله is very stn and
very سبحانه
وتالى
next سبحانه
وتعالى الله
‏sinc
pr
الله
wor and as for those they call upon
other allah those ids those angs
those wor
other those things
other
call
‏call in any
way in any way not at
all rather the parable of one who pra to
these ids to these false gods to these
false
deities
pra
الله
‏resp a who
of andes to water with his
hands earnestly expecting that this
water will reach his mouth and it will
never reach his
mouth and indeed the warship of the
disbeliever is only of l
الله سبحانه
وتالى
the po
of صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏id but these idols are not worthy of
their
worship is the one who has created all
that they see allah the sends for and he
is
the behind all that wear and all that we
hope
for our pr
‏deception it is based on
presupposition based on conjecture none
it is based on none of
it is real is only real in the mind of
those who worship other than
الله andes
ex
‏that when a person stands to worship
other than allah they are receiving back
only what the person who reaches to
still water
receives without being able to touch it
expecting that this water will
reciprocate his advances and his
earnestness and his
sincerity
‏los los none it will
be none it will be
consequence
we ان شا الله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين ‏l